Chris I want to know right off the bat
morale and Cleveland for sports fans
right now is it what I think there are
there's panic I think there's panic
definitely in the air look nobody
thought look I picked the Cavaliers in
five but I so didn't pick them you know
dick that they would go five and the
series to be tied at two right now the
way they took care of business those
first two games and and they're going
for Toronto and how they manhandled him
how biz not be on boards become the
second coming of chamber matumbo yeah
you wouldn't I could I wouldn't even
imagine this my wildest dreams so
there's definitely panic in the air
because as you guys know Cleveland fans
have seen this episode atomic to before
and Chris I hate to bring it up at the
30 for 30 the other day on believe land
it's just it's setting up a situation
like this I'd like oh no this can't be
right to be configured right hey all
right you're on the ground there in
Cleveland listening to sports radio and
your you write about things there who
from the Cavs is getting the blame or is
no one really getting the blame yet well
I think there hasn't been one individual
person to get the blame but I think it's
been collectively I think people are
looking at the Kabbalist saying hey you
guys got too complacent you know you
shrug off ten straight wins you guys
ought to believe in the hike yeah you
know I wrote about it I said it I didn't
think there was a team in the Eastern
Conference that can legitimately give
them a threat until the files came
around and I thought Miami would be the
best possible likely scenario so if the
Cavaliers are going to have to fight
their way to get the east and then that
didn't happen and in Toronto came and in
this way that the way the games
transpire in the first two games you
didn't see this coming you didn't see
Toronto having this type of a fight so
with that being said I think its overall
people are questioning team are they did
they fall to convict them to complacency
did they stop believing the hype and I
think we'll know that answer for sure
while the Cavaliers host game five
tonight we're talking to chris haynes of
the Cleveland Plain Dealer
Chris last game Kyrie Irving and JR
smith struggled defensively is this
backcourt good enough defensively would
they even consider switching late in
game keeping Dellavedova in if they're
getting torched like they did in Game
four well no I think I think what we
have is schemes have had to be modified
LeBron James went out of his way in Game
four to go and check the margin Rozen
from the start now the protector that's
all that's all well and good but the
problem was is that their Cavaliers
these are the schemes allows them to
switch everything so all tomorrow's
India all Kyle Lowry did was use a
screen to get the favorable matchup that
they want it and then went to work now
if the Braun is going to be on the more
full time he has to stick with him just
get them get through screen until his
guys ain't no helping I'm gonna get
through bust through i'ma stay with this
guy but look those two are all-stars I'm
talking about loud in two rows there's
mad beyond ville he has been a
difference maker here's the guy that
nobody like come on now Bismack Diablo
he was fit he was thought of as a
potential bus crystal 10 with the Cavs
due to have a guy like beyond bow
instead of Tristan Thompson down low Wow
well look uh I will say this i will say
if you look at the body you know body of
work Tristan Thompson's body of work
this is way more impressive than
business beyond bow but they ask you a
question right now come on now biz might
be humble is it is the prototypical
blocking big man in this in this not
just in the lead I'm not just in that in
the lead I'm talking about these these
last four teams that's left right now
he's the best big men out there you look
at what he's doing he's protecting the
rim he's gobbled up rebounds like crazy
he's giving them a spark with waving the
matumbo finger wag you know it he's
bringing life into that team you can you
view it you can account for DeRozan and
Lowry but what biz match is doing and
the way he's out playing Tristan and
Kevin Love it's kind of embarrassing so
you have to think that tyronn lue have
to come up with a scheme to try to get
that guy out of here now what is tyronn
lue gonna do about kevin love you know
not playing in the fourth quarter which
Kevin Love do you expect in Game five
what is the whole game so I would you
know our chance to expect that you'll
see the catalog that has played well
fairly well in the first 10 games and so
it is postseason but with that being
said it's like we will he's reverted
back to the Kevin Love of last year with
David black you stuff about three or
four games sit them down the fourth
floor and wouldn't play them at all and
it's funny because how i lose the excuse
of the excuse that he's you know why he
hasn't put Kevin Love back in the game
he's saying that hey you know Kevin Love
Without for a long time I didn't feel it
was right for me to put him in wouldn't
be fair to Kim allowed to put him and
down the stretch when he wasn't playing
the last five Jim is all I will hold on
that's what you tell them to do that's
right ok I want to say that logic so i
do what's a lot of food doing but the
truth the simple truth is he doesn't
feel comfortable with Kevin Love down
the stretch based off of the first three
quarters of love production air but
judging off that I have to say he's
right Chris we were talking to Dennis
we're talking a little earlier of like
if we were NBA player what city we want
to play in and what life's does a city
matter for your lifestyle if you're a
guy like LeBron James living in
cleveland do you do you see him out do
people see him out on the town or is he
one of those guys he can't leave the
house he has to have a chef and he can't
roam the streets and drive around well
no he gets around he definitely gets
around I've seen them I've seen them out
you know certain restaurants that I made
go to the thing about with a broader
this is how he gets around you will see
I've been at a couple restaurants where
I was probably sitting down there I'll
feed a security guard walking at first
like the sea consider yeah like a secret
service then you see a tall guy with a
hood over his head and he's walking
closely behind them and then if they go
to a path plane it seems like whatever
restaurant lebron shoes to go to there's
like a pathway for there's big this room
way deep in the back like I guess were
mafia me or something like that and he
goes back there and that's the way that
he gets out so he doesn't do it there
you know obviously the way me you know
we we tend to get out baby he knows how
to get out and have a good time
awesome hey before we let you go I want
you to finish a statement if the
Cavaliers lose the east to the Raptors
blanket colossal failure and who pays
the price it would okay the project it
would have to it would be everybody
involved obviously the Brawn James is
being read for that change the face of
the franchise but you will have to start
looking at Kyrie Kevin Love and a head
coach and then if it gets to that point
where i mentioned colossal failure this
offseason you have to start looking at
the trays because it can go two straight
years of you have in the highest paid
salary team in the league and you come
up short again yeah that would be
unacceptable Chris it's always great to
have you on you do a great job out there
hopefully your keep going at the finals
I'll take care of our Chairman the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience